[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un vacación informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
higuera valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
organización de las naciones unidas
denunció un recrudecimiento de la
hambruna en la región etíope de tigre
donde más de 5 millones de personas
estaría sufriendo desabastecimiento el
gobierno del país niega estar dejando
que los habitantes de la disputada
región padezcan hambre mientras se
mantiene el cese el fuego unilateral
la pandemia de koi 19 sigue tomando
fuerza en el continente africano con un
marcado aumento de las muertes y los
contagios ocasionados por la variante
delta la unión africana acusa a europa
de no cumplir sus promesas en cuanto al
envío de vacunas
y la crisis migratoria en el
mediterráneo y en el atlántico sigue
cobrando vidas ongs denuncian que al
menos 500 personas habrían desaparecido
en las últimas semanas intentando llegar
a las islas canarias mientras la tensión
diplomática entre marruecos y españa se
agudiza
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos
hablando de etiopía porque altos
funcionarios de la onu advirtieron ante
el consejo de seguridad que más de
400.000 personas en la región etíope del
tigre están viviendo los estragos de una
intensa hambruna
además resaltaron que existe el riesgo
de nuevos enfrentamientos en la región a
pesar del alto el fuego unilateral
declarado recientemente por el gobierno
federal
justamente el gobierno de etiopía
rechazó las acusaciones de que está
tratando de asfixiar a la gente de la
disputada región de tigre dejándoles
alimentos y otras ayudas necesarias con
urgencia
a medida que se desarrolla el conflicto
armado en tigre en etiopía el gobierno
central respondió con rechazo a las
acusaciones de que intencionalmente
estaban matando de hambre a la gente de
la región
no hay absolutamente ninguna razón para
que lo hagamos esta es nuestra gente y
el hecho es que estamos usando cada onza
de nuestra fuerza para sacarlos de las
terribles situaciones en las que se
encuentran en este momento y este es
nuestro deber crisis en haití los
comentarios se produjeron después de que
dos fuentes clave para el transporte de
alimentos en el norte del país fueran
destruidos empeorando el
desabastecimiento en la región grupos de
ayuda humanitaria dicen que fueron
volados por las fuerzas de seguridad
pero el gobierno oculto a los rebeldes
retire antes del derrumbe de los puentes
el programa mundial de alimentos afirmó
que grupos armados en la región habían
impedido que casi cuatro mil toneladas
de alimentos llegaran a comunidades del
oeste de tigre de tipo hub dave ward
online el hecho es que la gente está
muriendo de hambre
y más gente va a morir si no se permite
enviar ayuda para evitar que esto suceda
es importante que nos permitan brindar
asistencia de todos los sabedores
humanitarios de la región enfrenta ahora
su peor hambruna en una década según la
onu 5.2 millones de personas que
representan el 90% de la población
necesitan asistencia alimentaria de
emergencia había esperanzas de que se
restableciera el acceso humanitario
después de que el gobierno de etiopía
anunciara un alto el fuego unilateral
poniendo así una pausa al conflicto que
lleva más de 8 meses con la retirada de
las fuerzas gubernamentales el frente de
liberación popular de tigres recuperó el
control de la capital regional mekelle
esto representa un cambio dramático en
el rumbo de la administración del primer
ministro etíope había cnet
hablamos ahora del coi 19 porque el
virus se está propagando a velocidades
récord en el continente africano según
la organización mundial de la salud la
tasa de contagios ha aumentado durante
las últimas seis semanas
consecutivamente especialmente debido a
la variante delta el director para
áfrica de la oms se advierte que la
velocidad y la escala de la tercera ola
del virus superan de lejos a las
anteriores entretanto el encargado de
las vacunas designado por la unión
africana señaló la unión europea por la
falta de dosis y el incumplimiento de
las promesas al respecto
[Aplausos]
hay más pacientes que camas en este
centro de atención improvisado en
sudáfrica creado por una organización
benéfica los pacientes tienen suerte de
ser admitidos aquí donde los
trabajadores de la salud intentan
encontrar formas de tratar sus casos de
kobe juande se despeja una cama y entra
el siguiente paciente y es muy urgente
la necesidad de camas tratamiento y
oxígeno
estas son las personas detrás de las
estadísticas de la actual ola de
coronavirus de sudáfrica impulsada por
la variante delta que también está en
aumento en uganda y en la república
democrática del congo la situación
actual es la que las autoridades
sanitarias de todo el continente venían
temiendo durante meses especialmente
porque sólo el 1,2 por ciento de la
población africana está completamente
inmunizada los congoleños se quedaron en
casa al principio diciendo que las
vacunas tenían muchos problemas pero
desde que empezó la tercera ola podemos
ver más interés por la vacuna y las
personas comienzan a comprender las
dudas de la gente los problemas
logísticos pero sobre todo la falta de
vacunas explican el lento avance de las
campañas la brecha de vacunas entre las
naciones ricas y productoras
y el resto del mundo se está haciendo
más amplia a medida que la variante
delta se expande y récord lloró mientras
europa ha vacunado a una gran parte de
su población y en eeuu la vida está
volviendo a la normalidad
soccer championship
mientras el campeonato europeo de fútbol
está en marcha y se ve que los estadios
están llenos de jóvenes gritando y
abrazándose en áfrica no podemos hacer
lo mismo o volví calor vibra de áfrica
la unión africana también criticó el
mecanismo internacional de donación de
vacunas kóvacs su enviado dijo que ya no
es momento de escuchar promesas sino de
contar el número de vacunas que lleguen
realmente a los aeropuertos
y pasamos a temas de migración porque
ong denuncia que al menos 500 personas
habrían desaparecido durante las últimas
semanas el mediterráneo y el atlántico
intentando llegar desde países como
marruecos o senegal hasta las islas
canarias y es que marruecos y españa
pasan por uno de los peores momentos de
relación en diplomática a causa de la
crisis migratoria desde marrakech nos
amplía nuestra corresponsal e sofía
catalán
en sólo dos semanas quinientas personas
han desaparecido en el océano atlántico
tratando de alcanzar las islas canarias
ha sido la denuncia la organización de
defensa de derechos humanos caminando
fronteras su monitoreo sitúa en casi
4.000 a las víctimas de la frontera
occidental euro africana en los últimos
tres años y tras las desapariciones de
estas personas migrantes ninguna
institución estatal se encarga de su
búsqueda e identificación por lo que no
existen registros oficiales a los que
puedan agarrarse de sus familias de
hecho hace unas semanas a más de 8000
personas procedentes de marruecos
lograron cruzar al enclave español han
de ceuta entre ellas muchos menores de
edad y refugiados que fueron expulsados
directamente al país vecino y muchas
familias han reportado la desaparición
de sus seres queridos y cabe recordar en
este contexto que españa y marruecos
atraviesan su mayor crisis diplomática
mente años y utilizan la migración para
presionarse en el caso de españa en la
unión europea pagan millonarias
cantidades a marruecos a para que
bloqueen los flujos migratorios y ahora
marruecos busca que reconozcan su
soberanía sobre el sáhara occidental'
vamos con más noticias destacadas del
continente africano durante esta semana
en nigeria al menos 150 años están
desaparecidos en el noreste del país
tras el ataque de hombres armados a una
escuela del cual según el padre de un
menor al menos 25 lograron escapar en
otro ataque también en el estado de
kaduna hombres armados secuestraron a
hasta 8 personas incluido un niño de un
año en la residencia desde el personal
de un hospital en el noreste
simultaneamente asaltaron una estación
de policía cercana con secuestros para
pedir rescate se han vuelto endémicos en
el norte de nigeria
el ministerio de las fuerzas armadas de
francia anunció la reanudación de las
operaciones conjuntas con el ejército
maliense esto después de que el
presidente manuel macrón decidiera
suspender dichas operaciones el pasado 3
de junio tras un segundo golpe de estado
en mali en menos de nueve meses la
decisión del gobierno galo se tomó con
el objetivo de combatir a los grupos
yihadistas en la región
y el ex presidente de sudáfrica jacob
zuma fue sentenciado a 15 meses de
prisión por no comparecer en una
investigación por corrupción durante su
mandato de investigación trata de
establecerse durante casi nueve años en
los cuales estuvo en el poder entre 2009
y 2018 el aparato estatal benefició a
empresarios de forma fraudulenta
zuma argumentó que no debía ir a prisión
debido a su edad y a la pandemia de 19
y hablamos ahora de mauritania donde
coleccionistas de libros guardan
celosamente manuscritos de siglos de
antigüedad el paso del tiempo el difícil
clima del desierto de mauritania e
incluso las termitas son los peores
enemigos de estos coleccionistas que
intentan preservar el valioso
conocimiento de sus antepasados y
transmitirlo también a las nuevas
generaciones
alguna vez fue la capital cultural de
mauritania en el corazón del sahara
mientras los nómadas y eruditos iban y
venían muchos dejaron atrás algunos
remanentes textos invaluables guardados
en bibliotecas como esta que contiene
más de 7000 manuscritos antiguos estos
libros fueron dejados por peregrinos que
se dirigían hacia la meca o fueron
traídos de distintos países del mundo
islámico
estos son textos de poesía árabe aquí
tenemos algunos textos científicos sobre
astronomía y manuscritos que se remontan
a los siglos 12 y 13 que han pasado de
generación en generación la amenaza
yihadista ha disminuido en la región
durante los últimos 10 años pero hay
muchos otros peligros el mayor enemigo
es el tiempo y el abrasador calor del
sahara pero no sólo eso
abdullah ghulam es dueño de una de las
bibliotecas más famosas de la ciudad su
colección de más de 1000 libros escritos
en piel de gacela y con líneas de oro
está siendo devorada por las termitas su
método de conservación es sencillo pero
efectivo
llenamos los baldes con agua manualmente
y así la sala habitación no está
climatizada entonces el calor daña
pero estos baldes de agua humidifica en
la habitación y bajan la temperatura
pero las amenazas también acechan en el
exterior
traídas por los vientos secos las
frecuentes tormentas de arena son una
fuerza de la naturaleza que lentamente
devora las casas una curva mohamed
lemine está a cargo del mantenimiento de
la biblioteca sin embargo para poder
entrar debe abrirse paso primero hay que
sacar toda esta arena para poder entrar
ahora hay una duna aquí que tiene unos
50 centímetros de altura y del otro lado
está prácticamente a nivel del techo de
la casa que tiene 3 metros 50 de altura
mínimo filas de árboles como estas son
sembradas para combatir los vientos
arenosos para salvar los manuscritos
mohamed trabaja en la digitalización de
los textos un delicado y meticuloso
proceso con la dificultad adicional de
tener que persuadir a los dueños para
que saquen los frágiles libros de su
refugio pero mientras la memoria
sobrevive más allá del pergamino las
cápsulas del tiempo de chinguetti siguen
resistiendo a la prueba del tiempo
ocultas en pequeñas y empolvadas cuevas
del tesoro en el desierto
y finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con una canción que reúne a
tres de las más grandes voces del
continente africano se trata de este
sencillo titulado áfrica one of a kan
que significa áfrica única en su género
la lleva a la canción áfrica en la
ciudad benin angélique kidjo se reunió
con el maliense salif keita conocido
como la voz de oro de áfrica y también
con el nigeriano mysteries y reconocido
como el pionero de la música banco la
canción es un homenaje a la grandeza del
continente africano y a sus diferentes
culturas con esas imágenes los dejamos
pero ustedes también pueden continuar
con más en nuestra página web france24
punto com nos vemos más adelante con más
información
esto es france24
si acaso la gente
bueno
a veces
vida
si has pensado
áfrica
[Música]
[Aplausos]